and with that three years of
construction and anticipation are over
the David a temper quadrangle a three
hundred fifteen thousand square foot
building the largest building on campus
is open and temper himself was here for
the ceremonies well this place is
fantastic sauce Italia
not too bad and not too bad at all quad
is much more than a new home for The
Temper School of Business
it's the campus hub space that
represents a unique model of Education
it's based on bringing all students
together nowhere is the potential for
what's next
more palpable than right here in the
Tupper quad five years ago we really
came together with this vision of doing
a a business goal with was just not a
business goal a business school that was
just more than a silo where you would be
in a corner of campus and just do
business education but but a place where
you really would have people come with
the needs of business and the needs of
the world really now converging on the
strengths of Carnegie Mellon and The
Temper school I think we are uniquely
positioned to provide the intellectual
leadership and to educate the next
generation of business leaders and
entrepreneurs it's very much about
bringing together innovation with
business models to launch do new
businesses and launch new innovations
and through the interaction in the space
we'll be able to stand up new concepts
commercialize new businesses it's
quintessential CMU Tepper quad also
includes the 2,200 square foot War
Commons where you can get a bite to eat
students will study Modern Languages and
digital humanities in the askwith kenner
global languages and cultures room
cornerstone of the first floor is the
David and Susan culture Welcome Center
this is where CMU visitors can sign up
for a campus tour and meet with
admissions officials and student
ambassadors
next door to that is the 600 seat
Simmons auditorium it's the largest
gathering spot on campus you can find
the Tempur quad out here along Forbes
Avenue on the other side of the street
from the rest of campus this used to be
a parking lot and now it's the shiny new
home of the nation's sixth ranked
undergraduate business program find out
all about it at CMU edu backslash Pepper
quad and check out our social media
channels as we celebrate the big Grand
Opening